welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Doctor Who 60th anniversary special part
one the star Beast Doctor Who is
celebrating its 60th anniversary with
three special episodes featuring for the
first time an actor returning as a new
doctor and the leadup to nikui gatwa
taking over the role fan favorite David
Tennant is back as the 14th doctor 13
years after regularly playing doctor
number 10 Tennant last appeared in the
50th Anniversary Special in 2013
alongside 11th Doctor Matt Smith and War
Doctor John Herz we saw jod Whitaker's
13th doctor regenerate at the end of the
power of the doctor and no one was more
surprised to see that familiar face than
the doctor himself the first of these
specials is titled the star beast and
I'm going to break it down for all the
Easter eggs references and deeper layers
of meaning that you might have missed
but before we get started this breakdown
was actually written by one of the
nerdiest Doctor Who experts I know Gina
iolo who I first met over 10 years ago
at a World comedy theater in La as she
was doing an improv show called Doctor
Who live that I totally did not
understand at the time but I quickly
realized how smart she was and thank God
I met her because I'm still catching up
on Doctor Who I'm not really the expert
Gina is and I'm just grateful to have
Gina on our team thank you to Gina for
writing this so David Tennant isn't the
only one returning for these specials
Katherine Tate is back as companion
Donna Noble Donna's run with the doctor
ended tragically although not as
tragically as some of the others who
have traveled with the doctor rip audri
Russell Davies the original showrunner
of the new era is also back which fans
are also very excited about these three
together again you know it's going to be
amazing Davies was the showrunner when
Tennant and Tate were cast and is
responsible for some of the most
memorable story lines of the series so a
very very brief primer for the
uninitiated the doctor is an alien from
the planet galfrey he is the last of the
time Lords a humanoid race that could
travel through time in space visiting
different worlds or historical eras
instead of dying time Lords regenerate
into new versions of themselves this is
essentially a way to recast the actor
over and over again the doctor travels
through time and space in a tardis which
stands for time and relative dimensions
in Space the Tardis can transform into
anything but our doctor Tardis is stuck
looking like an old police box the
doctor usually travels with a companion
or several and usually but not always a
person from Earth in the year that
whatever season of the show is happening
okay now with that out of the way we
open on the doctor giving a recap of his
time with Don o' Noble the doctor's
current outfit and hairstyle is
reminiscent of the one that he wore as a
10th doctor with a blue shirt blue
overcoat and Converse sneakers the
doctor only buttons the top button of
his waist coat apparently David Tenant
insisted on this he also chose the
Fabrics the suit is made from it was
designed as a very classically Dr outfit
but not entirely the old look reproduced
as wrestle T Davy says this is actually
the first time that the doctor's clothes
change from regenerating typically the
doctor chooses new clothes this time
Whitaker's clothes turned into tenants
clothes Russell Davies stated that this
was out of a concern with seeing tenant
and Whitaker's clothes and that it might
kind of look like a mockery he feared
that moment would be weaponized and that
quote the notion of men dressing in
women's clothes the notion of drag is
very delicate and has to be done with a
men's thought and respect still it
indicates that there's something
different about this regeneration other
than just the fact that the doctor
regenerated into a previous face
speaking of which in The Day of the
Doctor the 11th doctor meets a museum
curator which is actually fourth Dr Tom
Baker the curator indicated that the
doctor would at some point revisit some
old favorites when it came to faces the
implication was that at some point down
the line the doctor regenerates back
into the look of Baker's doctor and now
he can add the 10th doctor to his list
of favorite faces as the doctor narrates
we get a flashback Montage of his time
with Donna intercut with Donna saying
that sometimes she has dreams about
impossible things and we see some of
these impossible things in this Montage
the Tardis hurdling through space the
rnos queen from the episode The Runaway
Bride Donna's introduction then we see
adall stalk a closeup of a Saron face a
dead astronaut in a space suit from
Silence in the library Donna helping
pilot the Taris the base of the Shadow
Proclamation which is basically the
Space Police only seen on screen during
the stolen Earth but invoked Often by
Doctor Who including in this episode
then we see The Wasp from the episode
the unicorn in the WASP which was the
Agatha chrisy one then this rock
creature breathing out fire which is a
pyrovile from the fires of Pompei which
featur Peter Capaldi and then we end on
a shot of a satellite in space after
traveling with the doctor Donna's memory
was wiped when she merged with some of
his DNA turning her into the Dr Donna or
the metac crisis doctor she essentially
took the power of a Time Lord into her
mind but since humans aren't meant to do
that her brain started burning up hence
the memory wipe the doctor put a fail
safe in her brain so that if she does
start to remember it release this sort
of elal pulse thing to incapacitate
nearby enemies but if she ever truly
remembers for any period of time she
will die tenants doctor last saw her
when he was dying and doing a farewell
tour of sorts he dropped by her wedding
to give a winning lottery ticket to her
mom and grandfather to set up his best
friend for life so he transitioned from
this Montage into a brand new opening
sequence with every new doctor the show
does a new remix of the theme song in
newly designed credits this is our first
look at this one the logo itself looks
like a throwback something that carries
through to the new Taris Design interior
and fitting since this whole whole
moment in who history is a bit of a
throwback this is a much more kinetic
and action filled intro and much more
physical as we see the Taris push
through gas clouds and the camera snap
zooms to it tenant was known during his
run for his youthful energy often
running around with the demeanor of a
toddler and this is an indication that
we are going to get a return to form so
this episode was written by Davies with
a story by Dave Gibbons and Pat Mills
it's based on the star Beast comic from
1980 which is written by Mills and drawn
by Gibbons who is also the artist behind
Watchmen so it was actually a fourth
doctor story adapted here for the 14th
the tartis materializes in an alley in
London and 14 enjoys a brief stroll
around passing by a cyber Dog store
which is apparently a real clothing
store but also likely a not to Cyberman
in K9 the doctor's robot dog but it has
these big silver statues out in front
that look like they could come to life
and start killing people 14 sees a woman
struggling with a large amount of boxes
and always helpful offers to carry some
but when he sees that it's Donna he
freaks out she calls out for Rose we
think for a moment that we're about to
see Billy Piper the modern era Doctor's
first companion and 14 says what what
and exactly the same way he said it when
he first met Donna and when he
transformed into 14 but companion Rose
Tyler is currently in a parallel
universe and it turns out that Rose is
the name of Donna's teenage kid Yas mean
finny plays Rose Noble a character with
the combined names of the 10th doctor's
two most love companions finny is a
transom which is worked into the plot of
this episode the emoji smiley face on
Rose's bag kind of reminds me of the
robot faces from the episode smile Donna
is completely oblivious to the chaos
going on which is a running joke with
her that she always misses everything
when Donna woke up after having her
memory wiped she said my phone's gone
mad 32 text V's gone Bary she's sign
planets in the sky what I miss now and
when she woke up again after her memory
white bail save kicked in she said did I
miss something again Donna tells rose
that she is worse than her great
Granddad and the doctor takes note of
this mention Donna's Granddad Wilfred m
t sacrificed his life in wilfred's place
Wilfred used to sit in his backyard with
his telescope looking at the stars
Wilford saw 10 teleport away from him
the very first time they met in Voyage
of the Damned and he probably told his
family all about that encounter maybe
this is what led to his reputation here
of saying Fantastical things that Donna
assumes are false Wilfred was played by
actor Bernard cribbons and fun fact he
played a companion to the doctor in a
1966 Doctor Who film he came back in
this different role 41 years later he is
the only actor ever to play two
different companions to the doctor
crions passed away in 2022 but he
managed to film some scenes for these
last specials before his death Donna
calls the doctor skinny man continuing
the ongoing bits of her giving him
nicknames like Spaceman and repeatedly
telling people that he's way too skinny
for her tastes anytime anyone wondered
if there were a couple the spaceship
crash here is reminiscent of aliens in
London where a spaceship crashes into
Big Ben and also Voyage of the Damned
where a space Titanic almost but not
quite crashes into Buckingham Palace
both of these episodes were written by
Davies so that dude must just love a
space crash when the doctor goes to the
taxi driven by Donna's husband the
psychic paper still refers to him as a
woman it clearly hasn't caught up yet
after jod Whitaker's regeneration and we
get to hear 10 catchphrase that we've
been missing for all these years in the
taxi 10 brings up nerys who is Donna's
best friend ofy that she was often
complaining about during her run he also
finds out that Donna gave the lottery
money away which confounds him because
the Donna he knew would have never done
that at the crash site unit is already
on the scene unit has been around since
the classic Who days that stands for
unified intelligence task force changed
from United Nations task force after the
UN asked them to change it they're
basically a fictional military
organization created to investigate
paranormal and extraterrestrial activity
it used to be led by radier Left Bridge
Stewart now run by his daughter Kate
Stewart the doctor has worked with them
for years although he dislikes the
military aspect of it and anything
involving guns so sometimes they butt
heads the place where the ship set down
is the Milson Wagner steel Works n to
Pat Mills and John Wagner the writers of
the comic the story is based on as Donna
and Rose head home some crappy kids
taunt Rose using her dead name and we
see Donna's protective mom instincts
kick in to high gear Rose is clearly
used to this though and takes it as a
reality of her life Jacqueline King is
back playing Donna's mom syvia and we
learned that Donna has lost another job
again a running bit for her her mom
knows that if she ever regains her
memory she'll die so she's really
downplaying the whole alien spaceship
crashing in London thing Donna and
Sylvia have a really nice conversation
about Rose and about trans issues and
it's clear that both of these women are
super accepting and just trying their
best it's really nice to see these
issues actually discussed instead of
like just being glossed over oh one shot
energy huh I think I'll try
it
who
[Applause]
so what does one shot's Focus shoe
do see
it
[Music]
eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order syvia mentions that she ran
into Suzy mayor who was referenced once
as a friend of Donna's it's interesting
that she said she was shorter obviously
like I wonder what's making people
shorter T and Donna were investigating
atap POS a drug that was supposed to
help people lose weight but turned out
to be a race of little blob babies made
of fat yeah the show is insane but there
is some similar alien thing that's
making people shorter or something Donna
says that her Granddad stopped talking
about UFOs and aliens one day out of the
blue again that's because he wanted to
protect her and prevent her from
remembering her travels with the doctor
the cover story for why Donna can't
remember a huge chunk of time is that
she had a breakdown but she has a
lingering feeling that that isn't the
whole story outside her house Rose runs
into the Meep who's just as adorable
initially as in the comics apparently
the comic was originally in black and
white and had different color editions
where sometimes the Meep was blue and
sometimes it was white so it's finally
confirmed what the official color is and
I love the initial character design of
the Meep it's got some mix of like baby
Yoda puppetry with the huge eyes and the
pointy ears some Gremlins Vibes
obviously but also specifically with the
long fingers it's baring the original
puppet design for et where Steven
Spielberg was able to get so much
Humanity not just out of the eyes but
the long fingers and the way they would
slowly clasp things the bug things we
meet are the worths from the same comic
run they have the very classic Doctor
Who monster design big eyes Ry costumes
sort of awkward movements again kind of
a throwback we see the new function of
the Sonic Screwdriver and when he uses
it to draw the square it reminds me a
lot of Mia Wallace drawing the Square
from Pulp Fiction this is a redesigned
Sonic Screwdriver interestingly it's not
the same one tenant used to have like
the interior of the TARDIS or the
redesigned intro titles the Sonic
Screwdriver changes design with each
doctor he puts on glasses as he looks at
the screen he previously said he wears
glasses because they make him look
clever but that was many hundreds of
thousands of years ago judging the
doctor's age is very hard for a number
of reasons so maybe he actually needs
the glasses from time to time the new
unit scientific adviser is Shirley and
Bingham she is the 56th person to hold
that title number one was the doctor and
we also saw osgod from kali's run and
Malcolm Taylor from Planet of the Dead
as former scientific advisers as a
doctor tells Shirley about Donna he says
and she was my best friend in the whole
wide universe I absolutely love her oh
do I say things like that now the doctor
has always been incredibly stingy with
telling people he loves them but that
might be changing after Whitaker's run
the doctor says that the universe is
turning around her again T and Donna did
have a lot of coincidences brought them
together and those ended up being the
work of Dak Khan who was manipulating
time so that the D who he had come to
despise would be destroyed by Dr Donna
we didn't get any answers in this
episode about what's drawing these two
together again my suspicion is that it
has something to do with the celestial
toy maker the old foe who's confirmed to
be coming back played by Neil Patrick
Harris the unit team gets infected by
the creature in the ship Shirley wasn't
able to Traverse the stairs with them so
she is spared for now as Rose chats with
the Meep again given some clear ET Vibes
hiding amongst the the stuffed animals
saying it wants to go home big eyes bony
fingers Donna says that the woman from
Abu Dhabi who buys all of rose's toys is
obsessed with gonks those are UK toys
from the 60s with big googly eyes and
hairy bodies knowing what we find out
later about these toys I have to wonder
who this one from Abu Dhabi is maybe a
former companion of the doctor or a past
or future incarnation of the doctor
Donna also mentions the Great British
sewing bee a British reality show where
contestants complete in sewing
challenges all hell breaks loose when
Donna discovers the Meep and the doctor
shows up Sylvie slaps him continuing a
long history of people slapping the
doctor he says here we go again because
they took a slap break when whiter was a
doctor probably assuming it would be a
bit cringy with a woman on the receiving
end the infected unit soldiers tried to
deter major Singh he could be part of
the sing family that showed up in a few
past episodes as well as Class A Doctor
Who spin-off ROM Singh was one of the
main characters in that show he was 17
in 2016 so he'd be like 24 now and this
actor looks a bit older than that but it
could be an older brother or something
Sylvie blames the doctor for showing up
right as everything goes wrong just like
companion Rose's mom Jackie Tyler once
did Wilford comes up again apparently
unit has been looking after him and the
doctor says he love that man proving
again that he is a warmer cuddlier
version than his previous self the
doctor bonds with the Meep over their
two hearts and shared use of Articles
instead of pronouns there's also a
parallel in the fact that they're both
kind of the last of their kind as he
holds out his Sonic Screwdriver Donna
takes it almost unconsciously from him
falling right back into step the
neighbor kid with the glasses watching
everything go down is fudge merchand
donni he's based on fudge Higgins from
the comics knowing Doctor Who we're
going to see more of him in a later
episode the doctor uses a sonic
screwdriver to resonate concrete
something number nine did and the doctor
dances to escape the gas mask kids Sean
Temple points out that this is mortar
not concrete continuing the tradition of
people who point out in details instead
of people freaking out at alien chaos
around them the group escapes by moving
from houses via connected attics this is
something we saw in the Magician's
Nephew one of the books in CS Lewis's
The Chronicles of Narnia it's just kind
of a briti thing they pass by the
sleeping guy who is a poster for the
comeback UK tour of the band Red Dawn in
the parking garage the doctor Don the
same or very similar wig as the one he
wore in the stones of blood he invokes
the shadow Proclamation protocol 15 pn6
this is something 10 used to invoke all
the time and Rose Tyler tried to do when
bluffing to the sarax in the Christmas
Invasion I addressed the
sarx according to Article 15 of the
Shadow Proclamation it's great to see
how much fun tenant is having revisiting
the character the doctor gets knocked
out which is also a running thing in the
truck we find out that Donna gave away
the lottery money because there are
places out there where people are in
danger and in pain and I could help it
just felt like the sort of thing he
would have done she's remembering the
doctor without really remembering the
doctor doctor number 7 famously said
somewhere there's danger somewhere
there's Injustice somewhere the tea is
getting cold come on Ace we've got work
to do his legacy lives on in the lives
of the people he's touched so the Meep
turns out to be evil and super creepy
this voice switch from cute to evil is
just amazing ah how to hell with this
the Meep is voiced by Miriam marges
who's been in a ton of things she was
Professor sprout in the Harry Potter
films and the voice of the Matchmaker in
Mulan uhhuh '90s Disney tenant flips and
catches a sonic screwdriver in one hand
just like he used to and when he tells
Donna that she can't get involved she
gives him the Donna look these two are
so great together it's like no time has
passed we get some very classic number
10 acting in the scene he always went
for big emotions and was very
comfortable displaying anger resentment
fear as opposed to many of the other
doctors who were more emotionally
guarded here he screams why does it have
to be this it reminded me a lot of when
he forced himself to save Wilfred and
was basically ranted about how it's
unfair for him to have to die to save an
old insignificant human I could do so
much
more so much
more a sentiment he obviously didn't
mean the way the glass separates the
doctor and Donna actually looks a lot
like when he was separated from Wilfred
by the glass but this time he can't die
to save her so uses the code words to
activate her knowing it will mean losing
his best friend all over again he
recites Westerly Pelican dreams tornado
clifftops Andante grief fingerprint
saturation sparrow and on Sparrow Donna
chimes in because she knows them too
they continue on Dance Mexico binary
binary binary some of these words seem
like they have meaning in the larger who
Universe Sparrow for instance could
refer to Sally Sparrow but others seem
like they were just chosen at random it
would be very like wrestle T Davies to
put a mix of Clues and gibberish
together to Dy B crazy to try to decode
them binary was what Donna kept
repeating when her brain was burning the
first time in Journey's End and now it
makes sense in the grand scheme of
things and as her brain starts to burn
with Time Lord energy now the Meep
screams
and but Donna is back baby and that Meep
should be very afraid Donna her memories
now intact scolds a doctor for the fact
that she gave away 166 million pounds
just because she was trying to be like
him the two is bringing an action to
save the day chel up the Boost to D
inate the plexx Dr and Sh fry the pleon
yes that oh yes is said with the same
intonation as number 10 used to say it
oh yes we get another round of what what
what what what tenant specialty what who
are you where am I what what the hell is
this place what donana is descending
calling back the moment when she told
Rose earlier that if anyone has a go I
will be there and I will descend end
there is a terrible moment where we
think Donna is dead only to learn that
the metac crisis passed down along the
bloodline to Rose and now it is shared
between the two of them and this is why
Rose has lingery memories from her mom's
life with the doctor she chose the name
Rose because that was his companion her
shed in the backyard is like the Tardis
and all the toys she creates are from
images of the aliens Donna met a diic a
jadun a Cyberman an adap POS and this
fizzy pink one that looks like a lupari
despite the fact that we never saw Donna
meet one of those and then finally an
oud the creature that predicted Donna
would turn into the Dr Donna earlier we
saw another stuffed animal that looks
like Satan from the episode The Satan
pit we get to this great moment we are
binary she's not because the doctor male
and female and neither and more the
doctor has always represented more than
what any human can comprehend at any
given moment the Meep is detained and
sent off leaving these cryptic words
behind a creature with two hearts is
such a rare thing just wait till I tell
the boss we're definitely going to see
this Meep again this boss in question
could be the master could be the
celestial toy maker maybe Davos the
creator of the Del or any number of the
doctor's old enemies Donna and Rose are
able to let the time lord energy go so
neither of them will die and Donna gets
to retain her memories and really this
is just a great rewrite of an ending for
a character who deserved a better fate
than the one she originally got Donna
decides to go on one last trip with a
doctor to visit her Granddad and we
finally get to see the redesigned Taris
interior this time it's even bigger on
the inside and there are ramps which
allow tenant to run and play and get his
Boundless kid-like Energy out it looks
kind of retro like at first it almost
looks black and white like original
Doctor Who in the 60s Donna tells the
doctor that this doesn't have to be some
big goodbye and that he can come and
visit his friends this part reminded me
of Sarah Jane Smith telling 10 in school
reunion that he abandoned her and that
she waited for him I couldn't I
know he isn't good about going back to
his old companions he doesn't like
endings and clumsy Donna makes her
mother's fears come true she spills
coffee on the console and the Tardis
freaks out malfunctioning and sending
them hurdling into anywhere in time and
space the Cloyster Bell Rings whenever
that happens you know some shit's going
to go down there are two more episodes
of these specials wild blue yonder
dropping December 2nd and the giggle
coming December 9th I can't wait to see
what happens next new rockstars is going
to continue breaking down these for you
but I am going on paternity leave so
it's going to be another person from the
new rockstars team covering these
Jessica Clemens is back to cover for me
during this period as well as some other
familiar faces from the new rockstars
team so please support them as you've
always supported me and thank you so
much for that support subscribe to new
rock stars and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
everybody